buying airline tickets can be maddening
but new studies are providing clues into
the inner workings of airline ticket
pricing and some of the findings may
surprise you here are four things you
need to know before buying your next
airline ticket
number one non stops are cheaper in the
past fights with one or more stops have
had lower fares than the most convenient
non-stop options but those days are over
for the most part the reason is simple
airline flights are full airlines would
rather fill seats on each flight with
non-stop passengers since they don't
have to split the fare between two or
more flights take a trip between Boston
and San Francisco for example if the
airline sells one passenger a foreigner
dollar ticket between Boston and say
Dallas and another passenger a foreigner
dollar ticket between Dallas and San
Francisco it ends up with twice as much
money than one passenger on a $400
connecting flight from Boston to San
Francisco it doesn't always work out
that way but for the most part you can
now click that non-stop only box with
pride and confidence and still save
money number two stay over on Saturdays
a study by Expedia and Airlines
reporting Corp compared trips in the
same markets that included a Saturday
night and trips that didn't they found
that while staying over on a Saturday
doesn't guarantee Yolo fare on average
airline tickets were 25% less expensive
if you included a Saturday night's stay
number three forget about oil prices
fuel prices account for roughly one
quarter of an airline's operating budget
in the past airfare and oil prices move
together and savvy travelers could wait
for oil prices to drop before buying
airline tickets but two new studies both
show that's no longer the case if you
see oil prices jump higher there's no
need to wait to buy tickets and finally
number four buy on the weekend for years
Tuesday used to be the day to find the
cheapest tickets airline pricing
executives would come to work on Monday
tally up weekend sales and watch a sale
with newspaper ads on
Tuesday nowadays pricing is largely an
automated 24/7 business and airlines can
tailor their best prices to specific
days Expedia and AARC looked at about
half of all tickets sold in the US and
found that in general fares can be as
much as 20% lower if you buy on the
weekend and actually up to 36% lower if
you buy on a Sunday the highest prices
tend to be on Thursdays and Fridays
airlines know that business travellers
usually only buy during the work week
while the most price sensitive leisure
travelers buy on weekends other recent
studies by booking app hopper and a big
data analytics firm called three victors
looked at prices found in searches not
actual purchases they both found that
Tuesday's are sometimes still a good bet
since airlines often run flash sales
early in the week airline tickets are
volatile so it's still worthwhile to
search for deals every day but if you
see a good price on a Sunday grab it
it's likely to be the best price you're
going to see and if you're really
determined to find the lowest fare try
booking on the weekend about three or
four weeks before departure that's the
sweet spot so let's recap if you want
the lowest fare booked a nonstop flight
on a weekend at least three weeks before
departure regardless of oil prices and
make sure to stay over Saturday
[Music]